Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody, I want to
start with something a little different
today. A judge has rejected a plea
deal for the killers of Amad Arbery,
which would have seen them spend a lot of their
sentences in the much less severe conditions of
federal custody rather than state prison. And
this is really interesting because it relates to
the way in which hate crime laws
and sometimes really serious crimes
can end up with people having an easier time
serving their sentences now. But before we even
get it getting into the details, I want to preface
this by saying I'm very much against the idea that
there should be. Punishment above and
beyond what's actually prescribed, like
one thing is we can talk about sentencing
guidelines should you get X number of years or Y
number of years if convicted of certain crimes.
But as an example, oftentimes there are some,
even in my own audience who sort of take pleasure
at the idea that those convicted of sexual
assault, in particular child sexual assault, will
receive punishment in prison from other prisoners
in terms of violence and even rape above and
beyond the sentence. For me, that's a failure
of our prison system. If our prison system can't
even keep people safe from other inmates, that's
a failure. It's not something that I say they're
really going to get what's coming to them because
they're also going to be attacked or raped in
prison so that that I find that to be completely
out of bounds and really an indictment of our
prison system. But. Without a doubt. In general,
inmates would rather spend time in federal
custody rather than state prison. The conditions,
generally speaking, are considered to be much less
harsh and severe, and that came close to happening
with Amad Arbery's killer. So let's look at this
report from CNN. A federal judge Monday rejected
the plea deal reached by prosecutors and Travis
McMichael on hate crimes charges, so remember that
they were convicted in Georgia. Travis McMichael,
we're talking about you're convicted in Georgia
on state crimes. And then there was also a federal
case that is still in process, which includes hate
crime charges. The agreement would have precluded
his federal trial in the killing of a Marbury.
Earlier, McMichael had agreed to plead guilty to a
single hate crime charge, interference with rights
in exchange for prosecutors recommending he serve
30 years in federal prison. Under the agreement,
the 36 year old McMichael would have been
transferred from a state prison to federal
custody. After completing the federal sentence,
he would have been returned to Georgia to finish
life in prison without parole. Five of the final
years would have counted towards his supervised
release from federal prison. U.S. District Judge
Lisa Godbee would said she was not comfortable
with these guidelines in Arbery's family also
opposed the deal. The judge has been expected to
rule separate had been expected to rule separately
on the same plea deal for Gregory McMichael. But
after the judge rejected Travis's deal. Attorneys
for both McMichaels asked for more time to decide
whether to change their pleas to guilty.
The hearing is next Friday. The family also
was against this idea. Arbery's mother, Wanda
Cooper Jones, was outraged by the proposal and
felt betrayed by U.S. Justice Department lawyers.
She told the state court judge to give the Mike
McMichaels what they deserve. Life in prison and
urged would not to accept the deal, quote Please
listen to me. Granting these men their preferred
conditions of confinement would defeat me.
It gives them one last chance to spit in my face
after murdering their son. And as as it says here,
these are often called country clubs. These
federal prisons, they have better funding,
they're quote, generally more accommodating.
This is one of those cases where
you and we have to see what ultimately happens.
This deal has been rejected. We have to see
until something is accepted, we need to wait
before we really comment. This is sort of the
opposite of what hate crimes are supposed
to hate crime laws are supposed to do.
They did a worse crime. It was motivated by racial
hate, racial animus, racism, one might say. And
for them to end up doing easier time in federal
prison defeats the point of these hate crime laws.
Now your reaction might be David. This is why hate
crime laws don't make sense. That's a different
argument. And I do believe that when there is a
motivation for a crime that goes above and beyond
the individual, but rather to their membership
in a certain group or class, be it based on race
or national origin or ethnicity or whatever
the case may be of sexual orientation. There
is something more insidious about that because
it's a crime not only against the individual,
but it's a warning to others who are members of
that group if their membership in the group was
a factor in the crime. So for me, the issue here
is not that hate crime laws exist, although I know
some in my audience disagree with me. But this
is an issue of very specific negotiations where
first you've got the state trial and you have a
verdict and you have a sentence and then later to
say, Wow, this crime is so bad that there's also a
federal case. But the federal case actually leads
to a less severe punishment that seems backwards.
And so I'm glad that the judge rejected this plea
deal. It wouldn't make sense to say your crime
is so bad that we're also charging you federally,
but you're going to get to do 30 years in a
country club rather than in state prison. I'm
all for reforming state prison. I'm all for
reforming sentencing guidelines. All of it.
But when the crime is so serious that you have
state and federal charges, you shouldn't end up
with a less severe punishment thanks to having a
federal case. So we're going to continue watching
it and we'll see ultimately what is accepted.
I'm curious to hear from you about this one.